last thing I want to talk about today
before we get to voicemail it hasn't
been a good week for Donald Trump if
you've listened to the earlier parts of
this show you know that Donald Trump
continues to be sort of confusing and
erratic with his flip-flops and changes
of opinion you might remember that after
the first presidential debate a week ago
donald trump was asked whether he would
accept the results of the november
eighth presidential election if Hillary
Clinton were to win because you know
that's how elections are decided and
Donald Trump at the time said to
reporters absolutely I'm going to
respect the results of the november
eighth election seems that that has
already changed a couple of days ago
Donald Trump said to the New York Times
I actually might not accept the results
if Hillary Clinton wins he backtracked
saying quote we're going to have to see
we're going to see what happens we are
going to have to see what is he alluding
to here well earlier the same day friday
in detroit michigan at a rally donald
trump again started up stoking fears
about voter fraud and unsubstantiated
complaints of a quote rigged election he
told supporters again that voter fraud
is a big big problem in this country
remember okay I want to communicate this
to our audience so that you will be
equipped with the facts on it this
entire voter fraud farce of people
showing up to vote twice people showing
up and voting in places where they're
not even registered etc that is a farce
used by Republicans to make it more
difficult for people to vote in
traditionally non-white and democratic
areas research has found that there are
a few dozen incidents of in-person voter
fraud in something like a dozen or 14
years that it has been reviewed as usual
almost all of trumps statements also
carry with them some hypocrisy in this
case you'll remember I told you weeks
ago that Donald Trump's Co campaign
manager Steve benen actually registered
to vote at an empty house in Florida
that he doesn't appear to live in at all
we reported extensive
on that story when it broke and you can
check it out uh once again an area where
Donald struck Donald Trump is the guy
ennis in a glass house throwing stones
at everybody else uh-uh it is incredibly
disturbing and in in the background you
might have noticed I know that they've
been quiet deliberately amongst all of
these outrageous comments from Donald
Trump Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
they are very much under the radar and
they both said we're voting for Trump we
we support the Republican nominee but
they've both had significant problems
with individual things that they've both
done they are completely under the radar
at this point and it's abundantly clear
what is going on with them this is not a
good candidate for the Republican Party
and again Donald Trump setting up to
explain away a loss on rigged elections
and voter fraud that absolutely doesn't
exist he's worried he is very very
worried and we will have tomorrow for
you we have one new poll post-debate
polling but I want to give time for a
couple of new polls I understand will be
coming out between tonight and tomorrow
tomorrow we'll review the post-debate
polling between Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton and see how that first debate
affected things